they told me okay you you you will start
walking here and i'm like
no i'm walking in in the bank
and there are no you you're not walking
in the bank you you so they gave me a
really good offer
so i went to the bank and i told them
look one of the biggest security
companies in israel offered me a good
offer that i cannot refuse
and i i will you know i need to move to
to walk in this older you
16.
and then the bank said no you you will
stay in the bank we will not you you so
they give me a better offer
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by j ventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homeward ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel at stanford
leap and birthright excel and in media
partnership with ctek
welcome to another episode of 20 minute
leaders and okay if you're remotely
interested in entrepreneurship or crazy
stories in general you must must
listen to this episode meet eyal gruner
ceo and founder of signnet ayal gruner
founded silent in 2015. he started his
journey in the cyber security world when
he was 15 when he uncovered a breach in
the atm machine of a large israeli bank
and the hi-tech company they both
eventually hired him as a cyber security
expert while he was still in high school
at the age of 16 he founded his first
cyber security consultancy company in
bagasek which became one of the biggest
consulting companies in israel after his
military service he founded a startup
called versafe and sold it to f5
networks at the age of 24 for a hundred
million dollars they all funded sign it
with the goal of building a truly big
company
hey
welcome to 20 minute leaders it is such
an honor and a privilege to have you
here thank you
thank you thank you to having me
you know
what i mentioned to you before i already
apologized for this is that i i hope to
talk as much as possible about sign it
but your your stories and your
background is so fascinating and so
unique that i think uh i'm gonna have to
pause and dwell on a few key moments and
just you know by small wave background
and and we'll already get started
without even a big introduction tell me
how at 15 you uncovered a breach in an
atm machine how how does a 15 year old
get to do that i don't understand
so so it started three years before
and
my friends spoke about hacking
and i didn't know the world even
so i started talking in google you know
what is hacking what is aka what what
they are doing
and then in in my high school we had the
warm
spread in the network
and basically it's you know it shut down
all the all the desktops and servers in
the high school
and we are talking about 300 desktop and
servers
uh
and and i i as a kid want to play you
know
in the on the computers with my friend
so i start to look what this woman is
doing
how is it working
and then i start to learn the hacking
the you know the information security
it was not called cyber at the time
uh
so i started to understand how this worm
is working
and then i understood how to remove this
wall and then i helped to to my teacher
to to remove this wall from the network
and to to eliminate this wall
and then i started to be in ilc it's a
again a long time ago
i started to chat with other
you know
hackers in the internet and we start
doing many projects many nice projects
so i learned more and more and more
myself
with with friends
and then uh i i we went me and my
parents went to the bank to open an
account for me
uh
and i i looked on the atm start to play
with it
uh it was a touch a touchscreen atm
so i was able to perform the touch from
the touchscreen
to get to the internal network
and then i told it to the
to the manager of the bank they didn't
know what i want from him
so at the 15th
so
amazing so i
i went back home
and i you know it's it's a bank it's
it's one of the largest bank in israel
without names
but it can affect you know millions of
uh people in israel
so
i basically
called to a reporter that i know i knew
at the time
and uh and i told him about it and he
wrote an article
in
in one of the biggest
online paper
then after a month i came back to the
bank and i saw that they removed the atm
and then i saw another another atm
so i started playing with this atm
and again i found the same the same
problem
and i told it to the manager
and he told me now i know what i need to
do and i ask him what do you need to do
and he's like i need your number your
phone number
because this is what the chief
information security officer told me to
do
so
he took my phone number
and then the cesar called me
he jumped to jerusalem
and meet me again i'm i'm at the edge of
15th
and from this date you know it's a long
story i if you want i can continue with
the story but it will it will be more
than 20 minutes
and yeah i'm going to have to apologize
but i'm going to have to ask you to
continue because i think it's just a
marvelous story of of uh you know
deep curiosity and entrepreneurship
so after i after i met the sister
he told me
you need to come work at the summer
vacation in the bank
and i'm like okay i will do it let's do
it
so i waited and waited
and the summer vacation in in you know
in few weeks and then few days
and nobody is calling me nobody from the
bank calling me so i said okay i will
call to the see so and see what's going
on so i called to the sister and i told
them you you know you you did a joke or
you you're
serious about it and he say i'm always
serious
so i i got an offer after a day from the
bank and started walking in at the bank
at the age of 15 and a half
and then
after the end of the summer so in in
israel the summer vacation is two months
i walk there two months and at the end
of the two months
the sister avenger like a party he was
thinking that he he will get rid of me
after the summer vacation
but uh so he did there like a party to
you know to
to say goodbye for me
and he told me that that he was joking
about me walking in the summer vacation
wow he just told me you know he was
joking and i took it serious so
so this is uh
so and in the bank i learned a lot of
things so in these two months i learned
that
you know there is many companies that
doing this
and getting a lot of money of this you
know the that there is a lot of problems
the this is the first time
that i understood that it's so easy to
act to any organization in the world wow
understood how easy to you know for an
attacker
it was in 2004
so
it was so easy to act to any any
organization
and i you know one of the question is
you know what why why there nobody's
you know there is a lot of bad guys
outside
why they are not talking to any
organization and you know stealing money
and do all of these things oh
and then
and then i i started to see that there
is more and more
i you know hacking activities and more
black accuracy is doing bad activities
so
well then i started my first company
i will tell you the the story that
there is a story before this so so it
was a in 2004 it was a conference called
white rock fall
which basically was the
akka conference
uh all the actors there not all but a
lot of hackers from israel came
come came to this conference
and it was a challenge to act to a
virtual bank and transfer a
a million dollar from a virtual account
to your account your visual account
so i act to the to the to the bank to
the virtual bank and i transfer money to
my eventual account and i won named i
won
in this tournament
and then at the end
a company a big security company in
israel
gave gave away a token which was
basically a usb
that you can
you can connect to me to your machine
and it can save password
your password in this token
uh so i i went uh to their website
because again it's 2004 you need to
download driver to to use this token so
i went to the website
and i found
a big vulnerability that gave me the
ability to find to download all their
crm
so all the customers information and
everything i was able to get it
so i
contacted them
through the conference and then
i came to the you know i came to
they asked me to for a meeting i came to
the meeting and then
they told me okay you you you will start
walking here and i'm like
no i'm walking in in the bank
and then no you you're not walking in
the bank you you so they gave me a
really good offer
so i went to the bank and i told them
look one of the biggest security
companies in israel offered me a good
affair that i cannot refuse
and i i will you know i need to move to
to walk in this older you
so
um 16
and then the bank said no you you will
stay in the bank we will not you you so
they give me a better offer so it was a
bad it was a
better offer
to to to you know to get me
and then
and then i found myself working in in
both company in the bank and in the
security company wow so i talked to her
to to friend
you know uh
i wish i can duplicate myself
you know i can get more money if i can
do it and and you're in and you're still
in high school pretty much in in 11
years and i'm still in high school
i was the
professional running in the high school
you know in the so i was doing many
things at the time
and and and then uh
and then i asked i told it to my friend
and they told me open a company
so i opened my first company with that
16 and a half
and then starting uh
hiring more and more
more employees and you know this is my
first company called backseat
uh so this is my my well it's it's a
small part of the story
the beginning of the small beginning of
the story i believe that uh not too long
after and and after a military service
you founded a startup called versailles
you sold it to f5 networks at the age of
24 for 100 million dollars and and while
i would love to hear that story there's
a few other stories that i have too and
it's it's crazy to me that i'm skipping
over the story and but but you know on
the personal side
besides the fact that you're obviously
so
so curious and so driven um you you've
had quite a few personal experiences
that i think are are really inspiring
the first one is what you currently do
with your spouse and and working with
animals so you have four dogs and four
cats
some of them
but some of your pets i don't have some
limbs right and
it's it's intentional you're working
like that that's part of you tell me a
little bit about why you do it and what
is it like caring for eight pets
so so you know i like animal form from
day day zero
and i i like to help to it's not only
animals it's also you know i i if if
someone
if someone have problems then i can help
why not
uh
so you know i i always love
like animals all my life where the cat
you know sleeping with with my with
myself and everything
and then i started the you know i
started the i met my girlfriend
and she is a animal saver
and she you know she showed me this this
world and it's it's amazing world when
you see someone and again it's not only
animal it's it's i have a story for
another story of a woman that start to
stroke
in a
in a restaurant
and they
you know i did the i'm with foil and she
basically i i think i served her life
and it's not because you know
it's because you can if you can help why
not you know it's easy and
and so you know when you see a cat in in
the street that
that it's you know yeah so i found the
cat in a few years ago i found a cat in
the street
and i took this cat and we took it
together and
and we found we are not only keeping in
our house
uh you know we also adopting them and
then you know finding a great home for
them
so uh so it's good you know it's good
things to do
i mean i think that you know
if you think about it if you think think
about the
physical security you know if we talk
talk about israel we are
spending a lot of money on security
uh
and you know there is a billions of
dollars invested on missiles and
invested on you know all the
best brains in the world are
invested for
for you know
you know all the missiles and all the
all these things
and think about if you can take all this
money
and all if all of this brain and put it
in on a good things on a good reason
you know the
it can be different totally different
role
incredible and and you know you
mentioned a few times
that
you know you can help others it's easy
but but it's but it does take some some
power and it takes some knowledge and
and you've done first aid courses that
that i guess gave you the expertise to
do it and and being vegan and and having
a relationship with animals throughout
your life obviously
shaped your perspective on them and so
and you know i'm i'm really inspired by
by your
you know your thinking that it really is
as simple as helping people it does
require some expertise but but your
attitude towards it i think is
incredible
selling a company for a hundred million
dollars at 24.
what does that do to a kid because at
really that point i know i'm 25 i'm
still a little kid
what does that do what does it do having
two jobs competing offers at 16.
yeah so
so
after
i sold my first company i remember i
don't remember exactly who is it but i
think the investor called me
and told me that in the first
six months
not to do nothing with the money you
know keep the money in the bank
and i didn't listen to it
so
so you do you do a few stupid things
like you know buying few stupid things
and by the way if someone if if someone
of my friend is doing an exit
um the first thing that i'm doing is
calling them and tell them you know six
months keep the money
you know i i didn't listen and it's not
good so you need to listen you know six
months keep the money in the in the bank
and don't do nothing
you know the the the
after you sold the company at the age of
24 you you are asking yourself what now
you know what is my next okay money is
not
not an issue anymore
so what now what is my you know
what i want to do
so i was thinking about many things
uh you know i was thinking about
education
uh i also
walked in uh
at the edge of
the age of
22. i
it's called the
early and entrepreneur in israel
so i walked with
let's say
not an easy community uh which was uh
very hard for you know for them to to to
be in this uh program
uh
but but i learned a lot you know and
again helping two people
and show them that they can dream this
is something you know this is something
important
so i was thinking about education i was
thinking about
government i was thinking about
you know things like this uh
and then i i was thinking about creating
something big
and you know 100 million it's it's okay
but it's it's not big enough for me so
it was fast so i so because of this i
started basically sign it
hey um
this was one of the most enjoyable
episodes i've had and i really
appreciate you taking the time to do
this i'm already reserving you for
another episode
to talk specifically about sign it but i
think that hearing your journey
so unconventional so unique
and when i think that your attitude
towards life and towards the things that
you do is is just admirable and and i'm
gonna re-listen to this episode a few
times myself and i really hope that my
friends do as well because
in today's world as we're all pushing
forward as quickly as possible and
things are moving fast and the
expectation is that you know if you
don't build a billion dollar company
then then you haven't done something
meaningful and you know i think that it
distracts a lot of time from from the
real things in life which is
saving a person when they need help or
or helping animals that are in need or
generally being good human beings and
and and i i'm really inspired by this
conversation so thank you for that and i
want to go back now a little bit
further in time and ask you what really
fascinated you as a kid before cyber
before at the age of 12 you you learned
the word hacking what what really drove
your curiosity before then
so so i think one of the things that uh
that is like really
i'm very curious i i want to know
everything and i want to know how is
everything is working
from from an atm machine
to a it can be a clock you know that you
open the clock and then you cannot you
don't know how to return it back and
then you learn how to return it back you
know so so i want to you know everything
to learn how it's work
uh
and to understand how everything is
working so it was when when you went to
the internet how you know how you build
the website amazing you know the first
things how you how you build a server
are you how you create the malware what
is the malware how is working how is it
working you know
how you still ma you know how our
knockout can steal money from the bank
and so on so
they kill us you know to to know
and to learn and to understand
everything i was talking this is
something that you know fascinated me
as a kid
it's not only as a kid it's it's today
my
few times that i'm walking with my
girlfriend and we i see
i don't know
something that
it's so it's look interesting i'm i'm
can spend an hour on these things and my
girlfriend
don't understand me but this is what i
love no i i want to understand
everything and and what inspires you
today
so
so i think the
the
the ability
to
to you know to create something that
will change so you you remember the in
the first step in the in the beginning
of the episode i said to you that it was
so easy to act to any organization
and it's still today but it's really
really easy to act to
i think 95 of the organization it's
really really easy to act to the
organization in the world
so i think to change it to have
a fundamental
you know technology that can change
these things and can be
affordable and easy
and simple
one of the biggest challenges in cyber
security is the operation
and the complexity and the chaos
in cyber security there is too many
solution
there is too many problems
and you know the
chief information security don't know
what to do you don't know which product
to choose you don't know you know
that if you need to buy
19 different solutions and you need to
integrate it's a it's a big chaos
and
to to simplify it to to change it
uh and to help
the
not only the big organization also the
mid market the small medium enterprise
organization or or the small medium
businesses organization to help them to
protect themselves
in a really really good way
so the so the attacker
will we you know will go
other places
this is something that
fascinates me as a as a person to change
something in the world
that
but sign it can say you know we
we
able to
to simplify
the the cyber security chaos and what
are three words that you would use to
describe yourself
so i'm i'm
i'm
really motivated meaning that if i have
if i have a goal
you need i think someone need to kill me
that i will not get to this goal
uh this is something that uh
this like i'm i'm very focused uh on the
target and motivated to achieve the goal
uh
the other things is that i'm very
positive
there is people that say that i'm too
positive meaning i something really bad
can happen
and i can see the good things in this
thing like i'm always positive and and
so positive focus and and motivate i
think this is the the truth
this was amazing um we're gonna do
another episode on cyanide because the
work that you're doing there
you know you're you're after your series
c and you're truly building a big
company it's not just a mission and then
i really i love your attitude and i'm
inspired by it so thank you very very
much and stay safe and stay healthy
[Music]